[Music]
everybody asking all the time how do you
keep everything moving forward when
you're traveling all over the place and
this is a good example I'm out in
California here at the Sony lot shooting
season 11 of shark tank now this is
pretty industrious because you get up at
5:00 in the morning if you want to get a
workout you got to get up set a 4:45 5
o'clock get an hour and maybe come up
get ready you're picked up 6:30 7
o'clock go to the studio but really what
happens is your hotel room becomes your
sort of center of operations and in
order to make that work I do a bunch of
things I've learned over the years
really make it easy so first of all you
got to set up sort of a command control
center I use three different screens I
know it sounds crazy but if you think
about it if you're doing you know a
voice call or a video call with somebody
that's on one screen you're reading a
document you're working on a deal maybe
that's the second screen and then you're
actually typing back and forth on a
third you know laptops it becomes so
light and small now you can get away
with this I carry three different
devices on the surface the two -
Microsoft services an Apple iPad and
then two phones let me show you some
other tricks I do you know at the end of
the day when you're on the road and
you're kind of dressing for shark tank
the only difference is in my wardrobe
are basically watches cufflinks type in
that's about it and one other thing pans
so here's what I do I actually travel
with a whole bunch of these things and I
match them together have a look at this
okay here's the command center three
screens a whole bunch of stuff here I'm
going to walk you through now because I
wear the same suit all the time black
suit black tie crisp white shirt there's
not a whole lot I can mess around with
so I love pens
I love watches and I love cufflinks
that's kind of about what you got for me
is jewelry so here's what I try to do
every morning I brought six different
watches from my collections I love to
call it then I'm gonna be wearing an
every different shoot day so you know if
you watch Shark Tank you'll notice I'm
wearing a different watch every single
day but they all have one thing in
common they all have a red band now this
little puppy here is a very new and
rather controversial watch
this is the new AP code 11:59 this
perpetual calendar I have it on a winder
because I don't want it to run out you
know when you're gonna count when a
professional calendar runs out it's a
total pain in the ass you don't want
that to happen so I put this on for an
hour in the morning I'm just showing you
how it's working here I've also brought
a whole bunch of other watches I've got
a Daytona Panda on this wrist red band
here's another hulk this is the Green
Hulk here we have an AP this is
beautiful of Royal Oak this is known as
the Jumbo here we have the Pepsi and
also the new Batman some people call it
the Batgirl I love all these watches
they all have red bands on them and
there's a reason for that I'm known for
red bands I like to ever advance this ap
integration was really complicated
getting this ap jumbo to a red band took
a tremendous amount of work in
cooperation with an MRP gaya' themselves
give me the special clasps and
everything else and then rubber B had to
do the modification I don't own any of
rubber B people keep asking why am i
endorsed a long time why because it's a
fantastic band and the integration with
the clasp and with the actual elements
of the watch is almost perfect when you
look at it it looks like it belongs on
the watch which is absolutely tremendous
now with these red bands I want to get a
little acquitted I'm on going on here so
I'm using each day also different pens
this is the new James Dean from mold
long but it's not just a pen you want to
think about which inks you're going to
be writing with they get all those close
shots on Shark Tank so I spoke to Moll
blonde they've luckily provided me with
some really interesting eclectic inks
there's as artists and stuff here this
is um let me show you this this is a
royal purple that was issued for the
Beatles issue and it's just fantastic
Beatles made special pens here's one of
them it's also a gorgeous nib on this
this is a writing instrument it's just
fantastic it actually looks like a
microphone top and a control knob in a
recording studio with all the imageries
of the Beatle but Beatles but if you
think about the Beatles sergeant
Pepper's album which is sort of the
theme for this
that was a royal blue and this is just
spectacular this ink is just gorgeous
it's a really rich royal blue ink and so
I've been using that when I've been
writing on the set for the last three
days in some very interesting pens and
lastly you know when you're matching up
on the links for this AP this is a rose
gold so these gold Tiffany cufflinks are
perfect with it and of course you want
to have when you're doing that a gold
tie pin to match and then I use my
classic for all the rest of the steel
watches the Daytona's and the steel IP I
just love these these are a really
interesting story one of the things you
probably don't know about when you're
shooting is everything has to be cleared
by compliance you have to go back to the
company that made these and get them to
agree that they're going to appear on
Shark Tank and this took months and
months and months every single one of
these pens all of these tie pins all of
these watches had to go through
compliance and the red bands and
everything else it's just a crazy
process of how I have to make television
show you something else this is my my
belt that I've worn from the very first
episode of shark tank and you can see
here it's marred it's got full of
scrapes this is where the microphone is
attached to my belt and has been for ten
years I'm kind of superstitious on this
I want the same belt every time I shoot
helps me get better deals but all the
sound people know it has the belt
because you can see how this thing has
been worn out you know and living in a
hotel room like this you want to kind of
think about other things too I tell the
staff look can you have some fresh fruit
for me because I get up so early and I
come back so late I don't want to have a
meal it's better just to crunch out an
apple or maybe an orange or a banana or
something because you're getting home
sometimes ten eleven you got to get up
at 4:45 in the morning that's the nature
of making television a lot of people
don't realize it's that much work it
takes a long time takes about an hour
sometimes an hour gonna have to shoot
one deal
maybe that's only seven minutes of
television or maybe never errors you
never know
that's the whole point
so I keep a bunch of other stuff around
the room I'm going to show you over here
you know always keep a little red wine
around but most importantly you got to
have that fresh fruit you know that's
the stuff you live off always keep
yourself hydrated no question about that
and you know I have some other wardrobe
here I thought I'd show you I'm doing a
shoot while I'm here in LA for my chef
wonderful shutdown Breann so you know I
try and keep this available that's sort
of my chef outfit there's the wonderful
logo I'm doing pretty well with that
meat you know I'm doing cakes meats
chocolates now I love it because I go
around the world looking for all these
delicacies so the great the good thing
about having a guitar around is you know
you get a day off like today you want to
play every day and want to keep your
chops up keep your calluses crispy and
your fingers guitar guitar still know
what I'm talking about but the idea is
that you know what I like to do is write
what I call little stingers my own music
so I can put it into my own social media
and my own videos and everything else
it's just not have to deal with all
those crazy music rights such a hassle
sync rights publishing rights all that
stuff real headache but when you write
your own so the idea is you you sit
around mess you know get a few riffs
going record them in the in the hotel
room so you just remember what you did
and then go into the studio clean it up
and lay it down so you just kind of
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the idea you know try and find
something you like clean it up in the
studio lay it down in your video save a
ton of time my music writes plus it's
just fun to mess around in a hotel room
the guitar you got us somebody's in town
everywhere are everywhere I go sometimes
I leave guitars in hotel rooms all over
New York I've got guitars and amplifiers
just you know when I get back from the
studio to do something anyways I have a
little insight on how this all works you
want to kind of keep yourself busy here
on the road it can be very boring and
you want to stay out of the bar you
don't wanna be drinking this a lot of
calories and you got to have stuff to do
so command center wardrobe bring your
watches on the road your writing
instruments some great ink few guitars
keep yourself busy
[Music]
[Applause]